the value is that it's non-conf discc
money the most secure network in the
world people who are dumb enough to hold
it incorrectly on centralized exchanges
where you would hold the tokenized gold
so I would never Advocate ever for
holding your Bitcoin or your gold tokens
on a centralized exchange always hold it
in a non-custodial way that way it can
never be seized they tried to do it in
Canada they literally reached out to um
companies who provide the non-custodial
software wallets or um Hardware wallets
they said can we have the names and the
address is of those people that own
those funds we can't we can't stop it if
that's by Design nothing in the world
nothing in the world is the same as that